today the Matt wall show Hollywood
released a historic groundbreaking gay
romantic comedy that nobody went to see
does this mean that we're all going to
be accused of homophobia for not
supporting the film well yes of course
it does also an investigative report
from the daily wire reveals that the
pro-trans student walkouts in Virginia
last week were not exactly what they
appeared to be plus Camilla Harris wants
to provide Hurricane Relief to all the
people in Florida who need it except the
white ones in our daily cancellation at
long last David French finally pens the
conservative case for transitioning
minors all of that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
inside every Progressive is a
totalitarian screaming to get out and
the team at front page magazine has been
unmasking these totalitarians since the
earliest days of the internet founded by
David Horowitz a former red diaper baby
and new leftist who ultimately became an
enemy of the left and a best-selling
author as well front page magazine has
spent over two decades combating the
radical left's efforts to destroy
America there are two new podcasts the
right take with Mark tapson and the
Jason Hill show offer riveting
interviews and insightful coverage of
politics culture and current events the
right take with Mark Thompson offers
fascinating in-depth cultural commentary
as well as interviews with well-known
conservative thinkers like Heather
McDonald Michael Walsh and Mary Grabber
the Jason Hill show offers thoughtful
deep Dives about the ideologies of the
radical left and interviews with
renowned intellectuals like Peter wood
and Bruce Gilley it takes a village to
combat the radical left's efforts to
destroy America and that's why as a fan
of my show you should also check out
these guys over at front page magazine
by visiting frontpagemag.com and while
you're there support they're caused by
making a tax deductible donation inside
every Progressive is a totalitarian
screaming to get out and no one
understands that better than the team at
front page magazine so go check out
frontpagemag.com today
well you may not have noticed that in
fact it seems certain that you did not
notice it but over the weekend a truly
historic moment occurred a movie called
Bros was released by Universal Pictures
Bros is historic because it is gay and I
don't just mean that it has gay actors I
mean in that sense it's like literally
every other Hollywood film and I don't
mean just that it has gay characters
again in that sense it's like every
other Hollywood film Hollywood is very
gay and Hollywood movies have a lot of
gay characters and themes but this movie
is a trailblazer we're told because it's
the first gay romantic comedy to be
produced by a major Hollywood production
company
and in case you're at all confused about
this fact
um the film's marketing material
especially its trailer make sure to beat
you over the head with a tire iron of
gayness just so that you don't lose
sight of how historic everything here
really is so here it is watch
hey guys it's Bobby Lieber coming to you
from the future home of the lgbtq plus
Museum everyone is really excited and
totally getting along
this happens to you bisexual awareness
week and no one has acknowledged it
lesbian history month was in March
nobody said a goddamn thing of course
lesbians get a month and we get a week
so what's happening didn't you guys have
an announcement this is a little
unexpected uh we are in a throuple
situation you're in a trouble
let me tell you what's Progressive now
being alone I love my life I love my
freedom I love my Independence that's
kind of sad that I don't want to be in a
throuple I don't even want to be in a
couple
[Music]
Bobby I had sex with that 65 year old
Jesus he's rich I don't know it's like
they injected steroids into Dumbledore
oh my God that's Aaron he's very hot
gay guys are so stupid I know but we've
been smart enough to Brand ourselves as
being smart start a little secret you
you saw enough of that you'll be shocked
to hear this but um
that was a flop uh not just a flop but a
full-on fat guy jumping off a diving
board belly flop type of flop uh they
were right you know it turns out the
movie is historic it made history by how
poorly it performed at the box office
it's the gayest comedy of all time and
also the brokest
and there's a Brokeback Mountain joke in
there somewhere but I'm not going to go
there I'll let you make the punch line
despite tons of media hype and a 40
million dollar marketing campaign the
film made less than five million dollars
on its opening weekend uh it generated
that poultry sum on 3350 screens which
is a humiliating average of 1500 bucks
per theater uh the theaters you know
they could have made more money just by
like sending a few employees to
Panhandle in the parking lot just in
abysmal failure but on the bright side I
will admit at least that the comedy did
get a laugh out of me by bombing in such
a hilarious way we must also note that
this film failed so badly in spite of
the Evangelical efforts of the media you
know who sometimes commanded and
sometimes begged us to go see this film
Kevin Fallon The Daily Beast for example
wrote an exhortation a few days ago
headlined
straight people I beg of you go see Bros
in theaters calling us to allyship
Fallon declared that the film is both
historic and quote miraculous and
informed us that it is our duty as our
responsibility as straight people to
support it he warned that if the movie
doesn't earn a respectable return we may
never get to see Billy Eichner make out
with a dude on camera again a terrifying
Prospect he says but Fallon also assures
us wary heterosexuals that it's a it's a
very good film on its own merits he says
the good news he says is that the movie
is crude raunchy and sexy
because those are obviously the
adjectives that are going to motivate
straight people to see a gay film and
best of all Fallen says Bros quote jokes
about life as a gay male over the age of
30 over the age of 40 even in New York
City in a way that feels authentic
now part of that authenticity apparently
is a four-way gay sex scene which the
writer promises Rings true
I can just hear some average straight
guy in Ohio one of millions across the
country saying to his wife hey honey
let's go check out this gay romantic
comedy called Bros tonight yeah
apparently it jokes about life as a gay
male over 30 in New York City in a way
that feels authentic yeah Kevin Fallon
The Daily Beast he says so he says that
we should see it so we could be good
allies also uh it's super raunchy and
sexy with all the gay orgies and
everything doesn't sound great we can go
to Olive Garden afterwards
you can imagine these types of
conversations but you can only imagine
them because they don't happen in real
life Kevin Fallon of The Daily Beast may
or may not understand that but the real
point I think of trying to emotionally
blackmail straight people into seeing a
gay film is so that when we don't
respond the film's failure can be blamed
on you guessed it homophobia so the rest
of this I don't even need to tell you
because you knew this was going to
happen right on cue the star of the film
Billy Eichner was uh ready with this
excuse he was just right away Sunday
night he was tweeting tweeting up a
storm this is all the fault of
homophobia
so he tweeted uh quote last night I
snuck in and sat in the back of a
sold-out theater playing Bros in Los
Angeles the audience howled with
laughter from start to finish burst into
Applause at the end and some were wiping
away tears as they walked out it was
truly magical yeah sure they did this
has this has very sort of um my
girlfriend goes to a different High
School vibe to it right you know this oh
yeah the audiences they loved it I mean
they were they just I I promise you I
saw one I saw an audience that loved it
I really did
anyway uh he continues really I am very
proud of this movie Rolling Stone
already has Bros on the list of the best
comedies of the 21st century that part I
believe I bet they did do that what's
also true is that at one point a theater
chain called Universal called Universal
and said that they were pulling the
trailer because of the gay content
America F yeah etc etc
that's just the world we live in
unfortunately even with glowing reviews
great Rotten Tomatoes scores an a cinema
score
Etc straight people especially in
certain parts of the country just didn't
show up for Bros and that's
disappointing because but it is what it
is everyone who isn't a homophobic
weirdo should go see Bros tonight you'll
have a blast and it is special and
uniquely powerful to see this particular
story on a big screen especially for
queer folks who don't get this
opportunity often I love this movie so
much go Bros
all right so you're a homophobic weirdo
if you don't spend
too much money and several hours of your
time going out to watch a romantic
comedy about men who meet at a gay bar
and then proceed to have group sex with
other gay men
you are a homophobic you're not just
homophobic you're a weirdo it is weird
that you didn't spend you didn't go you
didn't hire a babysitter and take your
wife out to watch that movie it's
actually it's a weird thing how weird is
that
a pretty Stark pivot in terms of
messaging we must say because the
trailer if you watch it all the way to
the end which I we bailed so you didn't
see at the end but this is in the
trailer the trailer goes out of its way
to insult straight people
uh it says you know straight people are
over they're irrelevant they're stupid
they're terrorists that's in the trailer
they're irrelevant and terrorists that
actually says it in the trailer and then
the movie bombs and suddenly it's hey
why didn't straight people come see this
hey you irrelevant idiot terrorists come
watch our movie dumbasses you owe it to
us
a slightly uh schizophrenic marketing
campaign
but there is an important lesson I think
that we can learn from this whole
Fiasco and there's a reason I'm talking
about it and it's not just to make fun
of this movie for doing so poorly that's
like that's 80 of the reason 20 is
because there's a lesson so some have
speculated that Hollywood knows that
films like this will bomb and yet they
put the film out anyway
and I've seen that a lot on Twitter oh
Hollywood knew that this would happen
because they don't care just about the
message
but that's not true okay because
Hollywood is still a business and you
don't make a film and release it on over
3 000 screens and spend 40 million
dollars marketing it if you don't think
it will perform now maybe you put it out
put it in a couple independent theaters
spend no money marketing it and then you
could just say look we made it see we're
woke or whatever maybe you do that but
you don't put the the money and support
behind it if you don't think it's going
to do well and so they did think it
would do well
they really expected it to be a hit
which only goes to show how terminally
out of touch Hollywood has become
I mean because there is in fact this is
the great thing about this
there is no genre of film less likely to
succeed than a gay romantic comedy
you have just combined things in such a
way as it is a perfect storm uh in in
terms of like making a movie that will
bomb it is it's the sort of film
seemingly designed to appeal to the
smallest possible subset of potential
moviegoers
so heterosexual women are
um the normal audience for a romantic
comedy
but they want to see a romance they can
relate to or or aspire to right they
want to be able to relate to it or they
want to be able to dream of themselves
in a similar situation
they can do neither of those things with
a story about two men hooking up at a
gay club okay when you got a bunch of
guys meeting each other on Grindr that
is not the sort of romance that women
have in mind
meanwhile straight men
are loathed to see romantic comedies of
any type my wife has convinced me to
watch maybe five total in 10 years of
marriage and it took some it took a
sustained emotional and psychological
pressure campaign to extract even those
concessions out of me
so she gets like she gets like one every
two years okay
so if if we're already reluctant to
watch heterosexual romantic comedies why
would you think you could get us to
watch a gay one
it's a it's a pretty bold strategy so
you're already having trouble selling
something to someone so then you go in
and and make the product less appealing
and expect better results
oh you didn't want to buy this car sir
well here let me have it painted hot
pink and then we'll um see how you feel
about it
this is the kind of tactic that made
sense in the minds of Hollywood
producers because they exist in a solar
system 50 million light years from the
planet the rest of us are living on
which is why their output is so
atrocious
but the good news the real good news is
that as they relegate themselves to
irrelevance Opportunities arise for
other people to tell stories and make
films and create content that actually
connects with the average person
now I didn't mean for this all to lead
to a sales pitch for the daily wire but
that is something we're trying to do
over here such as my film what is a
woman which is better and funnier and
more relevant and more important and far
more successful than Hollywood's
historic gay romantic comedy
and the other piece of the good news is
that um I'm taking the film on the road
touring college campuses across the
country my first stop is tomorrow when
I'll screen the film at Catholic
University in DC
so I hope to see you there
I guess this was all leading to a sales
pitch but what can you do
let's get to the five headlines
[Music]
uh another Act of Shameless promotion
here not self-promotion this is from
this is something that needs to be
promoted I need to start by telling you
this and I am calling on the sweet baby
gang to mobilize uh I need you out here
I need your support because on October
21st which is a Friday at 4 pm we're
going to have a rally at the Capitol
building in Nashville and as a rally
we're calling it the rally to end child
mutilation why are we calling it that
because
we're trying to end child mutilation in
the state of uh of Tennessee
and then and then beyond right so we're
mobilizing and put a stop to what what
Vanderbilt is doing and not just
Vanderbilt by the way Vanderbilt's not
the only now they're the they are the
gender clinic in Tennessee but there are
other uh clinics that uh and and you
know medical establishments
allege medical establishments that
perform these gender so-called gender
affirmation procedures on on children
including plastic surgeons even plastic
surgeons in our city or perform top
surgeries on minors so uh we're putting
a stop to it across the state
and that's what this rally is is is
about is about calling for that and uh
making sure that not just lawmakers in
our state but people across the country
the powers that be
realize
that this is something that we're
serious about
and we're obviously hoping for a big
crowd I'm expecting a big crowd I think
we're gonna have a great turnout though
I also have to say that as far as I know
no one's ever done anything quite like
this on this topic before now there have
been and there are uh smaller you know
events and people mobilizing across the
country which is great but I'm not aware
of a a big rally with thousands of
people on this specific topic
so
uh this perhaps will be the first and
that's what we're what we're hoping to
do
I am expecting
of course I would be shocked if the
opposition doesn't show up so they're
going to be there too and they're going
to be screaming and probably making a
fuss uh because they want more children
to be mutilated
and so I want to make sure that we have
enough to drown them out and I am asking
if we got you know a few weeks and to to
prepare for it if you're able to drive
out if you're able to fly up you know
it's it'll be worth it because like I
said even if you don't live in in
Tennessee
this is the beginning of a national
movement
uh all right
speaking of rallies so you heard about
ours which is a real rally and a real
demonstration now let's hear about a
fake one
it's from the daily wire it says
National media covered National media
covered walkouts by students supposedly
objecting to transgender policies from
Virginia governor Republican Governor
Glenn Duncan's Administration but an
eternal video of the quote student group
shows that it's led by an adult former
Democrat staffer and that the group knew
that a large portion of students had no
interest in the cause and simply wanted
to skip school now we talked about this
last week and I did say this and it
doesn't you don't have to be Nostradamus
I don't have to be a prophet to predict
it but I did say that number one this is
although it's being it's being sold as a
student-led effort I guarantee you that
it is not there are adults behind this
um people in politics who know how to
organize these kinds of fake Grassroots
efforts and they're the ones doing this
and I also said that a vast majority of
the kids walking out are only doing it
because they want to leave school
and you can hardly blame them given how
miserable school is and they want to get
out and so they're told that oh you just
go stand outside
but pretend that you care about this
issue and you're allowed to stand
outside for 45 minutes
most kids are going to take you up on
that
and then then when you start to
understand it like that you begin to see
that the walkouts were actually uh a
failure because
um it's kind of amazing they couldn't
get all why didn't every student go
given that they could leave class and
stand outside get some fresh air have a
kind of impromptu recess
why weren't they all out there some of
these schools is only a few dozen kids
so even with the incentive
as a kid that number one you can
virtually signal to your peers that
you're awoke and Progressive and all
that but more importantly with the other
even greater incentive that you can skip
class
that still wasn't enough to get all the
kids out
um and maybe because the cause that
they're rallying for is so horrific and
incoherent and insane
which is specifically they are they were
rallying when I say they I got I mean I
really mean the adults who put all this
together
but they were rallying to oppose
rules that would protect especially
young girls in school and give them
privacy and safety so they were rallying
to oppose the privacy and safety of
girls
it's basically what it came down to
um
continuous as in the in video of an
internal Zoom call obtained by the daily
wire The Pride Liberation project
bragged about having tricked the media
the group's leader claimed we had at
least 12 000 students walk out we were
the reason Joe Biden was asked a
question on this issue it boasted of
coverage from USA Today the Richmond
Times Dispatch the Virginia pilot The
Washington Post AP news and even some
International Outlets but in a debrief
after the walkouts one student asked
quote I want to know if anyone else had
this problem yesterday at the school
walkout we had about 200 kids
participating most of the students were
just there to skip class most of the
flyers I handed out got handed right
back to me because most of the people
weren't there for the cause to walk out
they just wanted to skip class
another activist replied I definitely
had a lot of those people at my school
they're bolstering our numbers we can
count them we can count them as people
who walked out for the pride Liberation
project they're still helping and they
don't even realize it a top organizer
rivka viscardo lichter replied
when helicopters are recording your
school they're not seeing which ones
care and which ones don't they're just
seeing the numbers so y'all slayed
following the group's extensive
coordination with media before the event
a local TV station dispatched a
helicopter to capture a small group of
students congregating
oh yeah because that's that's the other
thing right when it's when it's really a
student-led
um
demonstration that's something that
students know how to do like your
average high school sophomore
knows how to get in touch with news
stations and and coordinate helicopter
flyovers yeah that's that's something
that yeah yeah a kid can do that right
it's not like that indicates clear as
day that it was really adults pulling
the strings here
um Aeron uh
Arion Aryan I don't know Rowell a
college student and former legislative
staffer for a Virginia Democrat who led
the group on call told participants the
goal of mass mobilization is not
necessarily to make people care about an
issue the primary goal is to give us
credibility
in the eyes of lawmakers
for the 30 people who actually know what
the policy is and who actually know how
they're going to Advocate those people
suddenly have a lot of credibility when
they talk to our Virginia lawmakers
um
now
let's see a couple of things I want to
mention before we talk about it uh
says some of the core group of activists
on the call seem to have little grasp on
the policy they were disputing one asked
if this bill does does end up getting
passed would that stop us from being
able to have a gay Student Association
of course it wouldn't at all
um
in an internal Message Board Rowell
shared a talking point document that
told people what to say
including repeatedly invoking suicide
if someone asks if the walkouts
jeopardized learning he told them to say
quote how can my friends possibly learn
about photosynthesis and biology class
when they're worried about whether
they'll be able to come home to a safe
place that night
the talking points memo said to tell
reporters that quote I've had to talk
friends out of suicide at 2 A.M in the
morning and I've not met a single queer
student who isn't depressed
so it's a this is a talking points memo
that doesn't just give them arguments or
arguments to use points to make little
factoids and all that it actually tells
them it gives them false personal
information they're supposed to share
but they're supposed to tell false
personal stories about friends they
talked out of suicide at 2 A.M
and then and then the part of this is
that the people organizing this and
coming up with these media talking
points they're counting on the media not
noticing
that all the kids are saying the same
thing and suspiciously like 60 kids all
have a story about talking a friend out
of suicide at 2am
they're counting on the media not
noticing it or if they do noticing it
notice it to not say anything about it
and as far as that goes
um it's a it's a pretty safe bet
but all of this is just
perfect
and how it it it is is emblematic
emblematic of the left's approach
especially on this issue in general
because this is exactly why they use
kids to advance their message
okay the kid the kids don't understand
they don't understand the issue
most of them don't understand at all
they're not clued in they're thinking
about other things as well they should
be right kids shouldn't be thinking
about this issue at all they're thinking
about other things
so the kids don't understand it
and even most of the kids who are a
little bit clued in
who are more knowledgeable than average
about these issues for a kid even most
of them are are actually when it comes
down to it Clueless
that's why he had one of the activists
who thought that he was marching to make
sure that they don't ban the gay student
Alliance
which is not in the cards to do
now I'd be I'd be in favor of banning
that because I don't think that there
should be any there's no reason to have
any uh conversation or any organization
around around sexuality or sexual
orientation in the classroom or in
school at all
but that's not what anyone is trying to
do in Virginia
so they don't understand uh they're
completely ignorant they don't really
care about it
but they are just Pawns
all the organizers and activists care
about and they say they're on the call
they're very clear about it it's like we
don't we don't care if these people
actually understand what they're doing
doesn't make a difference we just need
the body count we need the numbers
okay we need to use them as Pawns
so that we can get what we want
all right hurricane Ian wreaked havoc in
Florida though the devastating toll
could have been worse without the
excellent leadership of Ron DeSantis who
did everything possible to get people
out of Harm's Way and is now organizing
relief efforts for those affected the
Biden Administration is also organizing
relief efforts but their focus is a bit
more
well targeted I guess
it is our lowest income communities and
our communities of color
that are most impacted by these extreme
conditions and and impacted by by issues
that are not of their own making and so
I mean
absolutely and so we have to address
this in a way that is about giving
resources based on Equity understanding
that we we fight for equality but we
also need to fight for Equity
understanding not everyone starts out at
the same place and if we want people to
be in an equal Place sometimes we have
to take into account those disparities
um and and do that work
do that work she had to throw that in
there at the end
only thing she was missing she got all
the cliches and only thing she was
missing is lived experience I don't
maybe I missed it but I zone out
whenever she's talking like anybody else
but maybe she should have thrown
something in there about you know the
it's also the lived experience of the
bipod Community they're they're lived
their lived experience of hurricanes is
uh is is is is worse like that is worse
than a white person's experience of a
hurricane I mean a white person a black
person could be in the same hurricane
standing next to each other but for for
the member of the of her person of color
that that lived experience is going to
be even more severe so that's why we've
got to make sure that we give them
relief first
now thankfully
uh
this really all ultimately comes down to
Ron Santos and his administration to
make sure that the people who get relief
who need relief get it and he is not
going to he's going to get provide
relief to everyone who needs it
and he's not going to do it based on
race
but this is what the Bible
Administration would like to do
even when it comes to Hurricane they
find a way to racialize Hurricane Relief
you know natural disaster relief is a
racialized issue to them
and she found
they never come out quite out and say
but what she's actually saying there of
course is that uh we're not interested
in helping white people that's it
because we're not interested in helping
them
and they're never meant to they're never
required to defend this this idea this
idea that's uh hurricanes affect black
people more than white people
what
can you explain that
can you spend like if I gave you even 60
seconds to elaborate can you spend even
can you give me a couple more sentences
elaborating on that idea
that hurricanes impact people depending
on the color of their skin
of course the media is not going to
require them to explain that because
it's totally indefensible
she also says of course she she
contradicts
herself and the usual leftist narrative
because she says that uh well they're
being impacted by something that's not
of their making
now I agree with that that's true when a
black person is harmed by a hurricane
when there are houses washed away by a
hurricane that is something not of their
own making but that also applies to
white people
now I can say that I believe that
but according to Camille Harris no we do
cause the hurricanes
so what do black people not contribute
to the to CO2 they don't contribute to
the warming of the Earth according to
her
actually the hurricane is of their own
making so we all did it
oh no but there's uh see there's an
intersectional relationship between
systemic racism and climate change and
so actually white people are more guilty
of causing hurricanes than black people
I don't know how I can't explain it but
maybe Camilla Harris well she can't
explain it either but she would she
would assert it anyway
Our Lives of tick tock has this report
it says uh Barbara Bush Children's
Hospital in Maine has a gender Clinic
which offers puberty blockers to kids
cross-ex hormones guides for boys on
tucking and guides for girls on chest
binding they also promote their services
in helping young children fully
transition and then she posted this
local news report let's watch a little
bit of this
like so many nine-year-old girls Lucy
tid loves to dance I love that I'm very
flexible and that I can do a bunch of
stunts and stuff in my dancing and that
I'm very athletic
she also loves to play the keyboard but
Lucy's life wasn't always this easy
going that's because Lucy wasn't always
Lucy when my child Benjamin was born
back in
2006 he was born Benjamin Thomaston
Bridget says Benjamin was headstrong
from birth and struggled with behavioral
issues but she says there were other
things that were different about
Benjamin we noticed at a young age there
was this tendency to want to dress up
and want to do what I do every day and
he used to love if I had high heels on
he would love to hear the sound he said
I love that sound mama I love that sound
okay
so there it is that's how
that's science that is just science
right there isn't it because that's how
they knew that their young boy was
actually a girl deep inside he had a
girl trapped inside him and the way they
knew that was that he uh he liked the
the sound that high heels made when they
hit the floor
and
and the reason we play
audio like this for you is because uh
you'll notice that you know this is not
cherry picking okay it's not like I'm
looking for uh the parent who who makes
the worst possible excuse for
transitioning their child
every excuse is the worst possible
excuse because this is every single
parent every single one
who has been profiled by the media in
this celebratory way for transitioning a
child every single one this is what they
say it's almost this exact story over
and over and over again well my son when
he was four years old he was interested
in dresses up so he's a girl
we had we had to permanently change his
body forever
because when he was four he liked high
heels
there is there does not exist a family
out there with a transition
quote-unquote child that had a better
reason to do it okay this is it that is
all you're ever going to hear this is
what it all comes down to always 100 of
the time
you have a a child a young boy
who makes the mistake you know at the
age of three or four being like
interested in whatever women's clothes
because they're because it doesn't mean
it doesn't they're they're bright and
colory you know and the high heels are
interesting because they just look
different than other shoes and so that's
why at the age of three or four he's
interested in them and she even says he
likes the sound they make that's what's
interesting about the high heels is that
he likes the sound they make which is a
very innocent childlike reason for being
interested in a particular shoe style
but she takes this as evidence of a of
some deep internal truth
and little did that boy know when he was
three or four years old in simply being
interested in this style you know and
being curious as a child in in his
childlike curiosity
because of that he's now going to be
condemned
to a life
where he is deprived of his own Boyhood
and eventually his own manhood as he
grows older let's keep watching a little
bit of this
at first the tits thought it was just a
stage he was going through
with their lives for good he said to me
Mom
I wish I could die
and I God could bring me back as a girl
and that was the moment we said we would
rather have our child
be with a different name and identify as
who she wants to be than a child that
isn't here at all I sprang from my bad
to see what was the matter that's when
the tits sought help at the gender
clinic at the Barbara Bush Children's
Hospital Dr Gerald o'shan a pediatric
endocrinologist is the medical director
you know about one in four will attempt
suicide about half will consider suicide
during adolescence and so our big goal
and what got me interested is how do we
help this population do better in the
long run this isn't a choice in most
individuals this is probably
biologically programmed make some
suggestions
that is such
and he knows that it's
the guy in the beard there he knows it
thoughts biologically programmed really
it is huh doctor so where were all these
kids for the whole history of the human
civilization
where were they up until five years ago
where were they
so you're positing uh a vision of human
history where there were cumulatively
billions of trans people who just never
came out of the closet because they
weren't paying a firm well if that's the
case then why weren't there why wasn't
there a mass
epidemic sustained over centuries of
suicide because what you're telling us
is that uh it's biologically programmed
all these kids are trans and half of
them will kill themselves or at least
attempted if they aren't affirmed well
then what
we should have just millions and
millions and millions of suicides over
the over just the last century alone
kids mysteriously killing themselves all
over the place
and yet that wasn't happening at all at
all
you know the child suicide epidemic is
happening now
indirect correlation
with gender ideology taking hold of
their generation so you might start to
connect some dots
the other thing you'd always notice in
these videos because again they're all
the same and so you'll be excused for
thinking but if you watch this and think
haven't we seen this already uh you have
because they're all the same
and it's the same story over and over
again the lamest possible excuses for
doing this to a child but the other
thing that you notice in these videos
every single time right
either there's no father on in the
picture at all so we're just hearing
from the mother
or the father is there and he's sitting
there he's this hen pecked
pathetic little worm just sitting there
all frail
saying nothing
so but but either way the father is
always silent
not a big surprise
if you've got a boy who's literally or
not literally but when they are when
they are literally attempting to turn a
boy into a girl
um that could only happen if the father
is absent
be it physically absent he's just not in
the picture at all
or he's there he's a warm body but in
every other sense emotionally
spiritually psychologically he's absent
he's just a nothing a big nothing of a
man
all right
let's see a couple of things I wanted to
mention
and uh all right so I've had this for a
few days and I wanted to talk about it
briefly Yahoo news has this David Simon
who's the creator of the classic HBO
drama of The Wire
which is uh one of my I know I'm not
very original and saying it's one of my
favorite shows but it is uh bristled on
Tuesday in defense of the show after it
was called quote the best piece of
conservative art ever made Simon
reacting in a lengthy Twitter thread
that ran to 30 posts seemed to suggest
the show could in the same vein
represent police in a positive light as
related to the fight against violent
crime and homicide while also
highlighting the wasted resources they
inhabit in The Wider War on Drugs
Simon wrote quote when an S bird mangles
an opponent's language into his own
rhetoric you can be a short of one thing
he's stuffing a straw man weak enough so
he can wrestle with it two things can be
true at once and in this case they are
and then he goes on from there so uh and
it is a really long I can't read all
things he goes on and on and on about it
but we could summarize it by saying that
he as the creator of The Wire
is very upset that anyone is claiming it
has conservative themes he just doesn't
agree with that and he's upset about and
doesn't like being accused of creating a
conservative piece of art because to him
uh that's the worst thing that you could
be accused of in the world
he'd rather be accused of being a serial
killer than to be accused of creating
something that conservatives can relate
to
uh or that even the worst of that
actually has conservative themes and a
conservative message now I bring this up
because I think it relates to this story
which was just put out by the daily wire
it says the nation's largest abortion
provider Planned Parenthood is fuming
mad over abortion related scenes in the
latest Marilyn Monroe movie blonde the
controversial Netflix film humanizes The
Unborn on numerous occasions and
includes the depiction of a violent
forced abortion that haunts the actress
Karen sprook of Planned Parenthood
Federation of America said as film and
TV shapes many people's understanding of
sexual and reproductive Health it's
critical these depictions accurately
portray women's real decisions and
experiences while abortion is safe
essential health care anti-abortion
zealots have long contributed to
abortion stigma by using medically
inaccurate descriptions of fierces and
pregnancy
Andrew Dominic's new film blonde
bolsters their message with a CGI
talking fetus depicted to look like a
fully formed baby
and uh then she goes on she's very upset
that this abortion was depicted now I
haven't seen this movie blonde I don't I
don't plan on it I know it got a lot of
hype because it's I believe it's nc17
um
but you don't see those kind of films
very often and I don't
from what little I understand of the
film I don't think it has a necessarily
conservative
explicitly conservative message and I
doubt that was the point the filmmaker
was trying to make however it just
brings us to this
that movies or shows
which depict real life
and and speak to real experiences
will inevitably have conservative themes
that's all we really mean when we say
that movie has our show has conservative
themes or it's conservative it's just
it's just real it speaks to real things
and it has a it also has a it has a
grasp on Good and Evil
so if you've got that going for you
in your film or your show then in that
sense it's quote conservative
um which should tell you something about
conservatism versus leftism and where
you want to align yourself
and this is especially the case when it
comes to depictions of abortion
because really any show or film that
depicts abortion or has that you know
centers itself around abortion or has
abortion as part of the plot
it ends up coming off like an
anti-abortion film even if that's not
what's intended
and it rarely is intended
but it just it can't help but come off
that way because abortion is is in
reality so grotesque and abominable and
horrific
and so if you deal with it in any kind
of real way at all
I mean your only hope is to go about in
a really glossy sort of way and there
have been movies that have attempted
that there have been comedies you know
abortion related comedies that they try
to dress the whole thing up as somehow
sort of quirky and funny
even that ends up failing I mean if you
were to sit and watch those movies you'd
still come away from them thinking this
is just horrible this is depressing it's
terrible
but if the filmmaker whether he's
pro-life or not doesn't matter
if he actually
shows the reality of abortion
then we say that we don't necessarily
mean doesn't have to show the you know
the the actual procedure procedure
itself uh but just shows what it is
and and then also crucially the effect
it has on the woman after the fact
if it does that it's going to end up
being pro-life just by default
inadvertently but still
similar thing with the wire I mean that
that's why you could accuse the wire
accuse it of being conservative now it
doesn't have anything to do with
abortion I don't think abortion factors
in but it does have a pretty firm sense
of good
versus evil
now that's not to say that the
characters and you know there's lots of
Shades of Gray in the actual characters
and in their own motivations and and
their own moral guilt for the things
that they do so there's that's where you
have complexity and that's that's true
life
but there is good and and there is evil
in this in the world of of The Wire
all right this is finally from Yahoo it
says it's been nearly a hundred days
since the Supreme Court overturned Roe v
Wade but some black women aren't letting
Decades of Reproductive Rights slip away
quietly on Friday black women from
several reproductive and racial Justice
organizations are challenging Americans
to put down their work and come together
for a collective day of action that
they're calling a day without us the
event which is being organized by
Advocates at the front line netroots
nation and several other National
advocacy groups also marks the 46th
anniversary of the Hyde Amendment
um
as for how the day is actually going to
work the general idea is that folks
would skip work and their routines to
attend an all-day digital teach-in
session starting at 11 30 a.m Eastern
Time
and so this is what they want I I guess
this is
Focus especially on black women but not
just them I think anyone could could
join in this already happened by the way
it's happened on Friday
so what they're saying is we want you to
drop out of everyday life for a day
and I think it's no matter what your
race is if you're you know Pro if you're
pro-abortion and you really believe in
quote abortion rights drop drop out of
life for a day and uh don't don't go
shopping don't go to work
and we'll show everybody we'll we'll let
them see what it's like to not have us
around
but this was on Friday and nobody
noticed I'm not trying to be mean here
but no one noticed at all
so the pro-abortion women dropped out of
life for a day and literally no one
noticed everything continued as normal
it was it was not even the slightest
inconvenience to anyone
uh which is not the point you want to
make
okay that's why you gotta you gotta be
really careful if you're gonna organize
an event like this you have to you have
to have some idea ahead of time of how
many people are going to participate
and it's also important that you know if
if you're trying to mobilize a certain
group of people that they actually have
sort of a pivotal role in society and
they have important jobs and so then if
they stop doing that job for a day
people will notice
but but you know like pro-abortion
feminists I mean what most of them don't
even have jobs in the first place
so it doesn't work out it's kind of like
if you uh you know you go on vacation
for a week and you tell yourself that ah
if I said my job things are going to
fall apart without me and then you come
back and everything's working actually
things are working better than they were
you know it's like things work better
without you
then you're in bad shape
and see this is why I would never
organize a a day without podcasters
event I would never try to do that
for a similar reason
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
Stan Thompson says Jordan Peterson
literally saved my life if it wasn't for
him I wouldn't have gotten over my
debilitating crystal meth addiction I
suffered for 15 years from homeless and
everything a huge reason I am who I am
today is because Jordan Peterson he's
one of the most amazing human beings of
Our Generation truly a rare gem of a
human being people like him are
extremely extremely rare it should be
protected and cherished at all costs he
wants nothing but the best for all
people man has a True Heart of Gold
honestly when the Liberals All Began
hating on him that was what began waking
me up to what was happening to the
Democrat Party and pushed me to leave
that party Jordan Peterson is demonized
yet a man who assaulted a pregnant woman
during an armed home invasion has a
statue built for him and is worshiped by
all on the left yeah well that's and
that's not by accident there's a there's
a direct connection there that um
essentially on the left if you actually
care about the well-being of human
beings and you try to make people's
lives better actually better then
they're going to hate you
man really as simple as that
and if you have actively worked to harm
people or at the very least done nothing
to help anyone ever in your life then
you've got a much better chance of being
hailed as a hero by the left
but it's this is basically the number
one sin that you can commit as far as
the life's concerned is to help people
because that's all that Jordan Peterson
is doing it it's if you didn't know any
better
and you weren't clued in at all and you
saw this you you'd be baffled by it how
much they hate Jordan Peterson
it's like
what why do you hate him so much what
did he ever do to you
so it's all he's just offering his his
insights and he obviously really cares
about people that's why he gets
emotional when he talks about it
so whether you agree with everything he
says or not that just the the hatred
is almost baffling until again you
realize that on the left they are
they're really anti-human
that's what it comes from
uh Brady says I saw this clip of JP last
night and uh the I thought the
marginalized were supposed to have a
voice line brought a tear to my eyes I
honestly had never thought of young men
identified as incels like that
and that exactly that shows how
effective the marginalization campaign
has been
um in in you put a label it's a certain
group of people you don't like and in
the case of the left they really hate
young men uh young white men in
particular and so you just put a label
on them in this case you say oh they're
in cells we're going to call them all in
cells and then that becomes your excuse
to hate them
and when anyone defends them and says
well you shouldn't hate this group they
say no they deserve it they actually
deserve it
of course tyrants through history that's
what they always say
they have their group they're demonizing
and they always say that well in general
I wouldn't treat a group this way but
these people deserve it
uh
and Obi Ken Kenobi says as evident by
the Frat Boys had Matt clearly just
reads whatever is on the prompter for
those segments with no prep beforehand
Sean the producer is a perfect
opportunity to troll him with an I'm Ron
Burgundy type moment just saying it
wouldn't even be funny because of course
I'm gonna I'm gonna yes it'll work every
single time
I'd read what's on the prompter okay
this is how this is my programming I
can't help it
Jake says Matt what did you and Michael
decide for your bet yeah we talked about
this in the in the members block on
Friday uh we're gonna have because we're
facing off against each other for
fantasy football this week and we were
trying to figure out what our bet would
be so the loser would have to do
something
um and we never decided on it so I don't
think we ever decided what the bet is
which is good because I believe I lost
and we never decided on what the bed is
I don't have to do anything I'm off the
hook
procrastinate procrastination and
laziness pays off yet again folks
the daily wire is hiring oh good another
one of these good uh a senior front-end
web developer to join our streaming
platform and e-commerce team you need at
least three years of real world software
experience but you do not need a college
degree just big league coding chops like
me in Big Bang Theory speak
I don't even know what that means that's
the show
you got to be Adept in HTML5 css3
JavaScript react native and restful apis
is it apis or apis
okay
and be Adept in that as well in
front-end web development if if
front-end web develop is
if front-end web development is your
love language apply to join us in
Nashville where you will upgrade the
user experience and uh Beauty not just
of our streaming platform but more
importantly of my sections on the
website so go to dailywire.com careers
to apply today also the daily wire is
hiring a senior vice president of
marketing analytics data and operations
I'm told that this is a high profile
executive role with paid relocation to
Nashville this innovator will Design
hire and oversee a world-class marketing
data and analytics team that is built
atop the marketing data stack from CRM
platforms to multi-touch attribution
tools to propensity targeting models
this leader will for example study which
daily wire shows and films most interest
the fans and also which daily wire host
is most annoying so if you understand
what a full marketing data and analytics
stack is then you should head over to
dailywire.com careers now to apply and
please someone do this so they stop
making me read this ad I beg of you now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well David French is a name famous you
might say Infamous among conservative
media Types on Twitter though largely
unknown outside of that admittedly
somewhat insular Circle French is one of
those self-professed reasonable and
principled conservative pundits who
proves his reasonableness by focusing
his criticism almost entirely to the
right he likes to focus especially on
attacking what he views as far-right
extremist evangelicals he believes that
the biggest problem in the Christian
church is that Christians are too
militant and too right-wing which is to
say that David French is just based on
that alone
totally clueless Because the actual
problem the church is quite the opposite
of that but up until this point French
had not spent much time
applying his brand of cluelessness to
the debates over gender ideology
which is a rather noticeable evasion
especially because he lives I believe in
Tennessee yet he has said nothing about
the Vanderbilt Scandal and still has
said nothing about it actually but he
has finally chimed in on the broader
topic and what he had to say is somehow
even more vapid and incoherent than I
even expected so I'm going to read from
his piece on the dispatch and he begins
with what seems to be an encouraging
note he says this
I'm a person who believes in the
traditional Christian doctrines of
marriage and sexual morality I don't
believe in sex outside of marriage
between a man and a woman I don't agree
that um uh trans men are are men or that
trans women are women and while I strive
to treat every person I encounter with
dignity and respect I don't use
preferred pronouns because their use is
a form of ascent to a system of belief
to which I do not subscribe
so I will say that David French not
using preferred pronouns is a curveball
that I didn't see coming maybe I
misjudged the man or maybe not because
he continues
that makes me pretty far right correct
well not when the right gets
authoritarian or closes its mind and
heart to the legacy of real Injustice
oh well see there's the David French we
know and love he goes on to rightly
condemn California for its recent
legislation making itself a sanctuary
State quote unquote for child sex change
operations it's a place where minors can
now come and be mutilated and sterilized
without parental consent French says
that that's wrong
and he's right that it is wrong
but of course he can't just leave it
there now comes the classic David French
false moral equivalence he says this
this wouldn't be 2022 if the story ran
only one way just as California has
escalated the culture wars by
potentially severing the parent-child
relationship when parents object to
various methods of gender reassignment
Texas now threatens to break families
when parents consent to those same
treatments in February Texas Attorney
General Ken Paxton wrote to Texas
representative Matt Krause and argued
that certain sex change or gender
reassignment procedures including
various surgical procedures and the
prescriptions of puberty blockers can
legally constitute child abuse under
several provisions of Texas law the
Texas directives at DCPS dfps
investigations are currently subject to
litigation and I have little doubt that
California will face its own lawsuits
but this is where we are now it's not
enough to disagree over important
matters now the culture War requires a
direct attack on the most fundamental
American Liberty interests
okay but how is protecting children from
a grotesque physical and sexual abuse a
direct attack on Liberty whose Liberty
is being attacked the abusers I mean is
he worried about the abuser's Liberty
well yes precisely reading on it says in
an ex in an excellent comprehensive
piece at public discourse Catholic
University Professor Melissa mocella
outlines the stakes well after outlining
the risks and side effects of popular
gender affirming measures like puberty
blockers she writes quote it is clearly
untenable to claim that parents who are
hesitant to rush their children into
risky controversial Medical Treatments
of unproven efficacy are guilty of
medical neglect but that's not the
entire story a similar admonition
applies to the right again here's most
cello given current divisions and
medical opinion loving and responsible
parents may be convinced that such
treatments are necessary for the child's
health thus it is clearly within the
parents sphere of constitutionally
protected child-rearing authority to
seek a legal medical treatment for their
child following the advice of the
child's doctors
and French agrees with muscella saying
quote yet as serious as the
Constitutional deprivations are outside
of criminal law it is difficult to think
of an exercise of state power more raw
immediate and devastating than the use
of state power to sever the bond between
parent and child it is a power to be
exercised sparingly in the most extreme
cases it's not a power to enlist in the
culture War over one of the emotional
and contentious contests of our time at
a time of profound public Division and
deep moral conflict pluralism suffers
from a serious disadvantage compared to
the illiberal e-liberal extremes of far
right and far left States should pass
age restrictions prohibiting dramatic
medical interventions for children at an
absolute minimum they must require
parental consent but they can express
their values and pass the regulations
while still remembering a singular moral
and constitutional command
leave loving families alone
okay
so we must congratulate Mr French I mean
he noticed how the left has staked out
uh an incoherent and morally insane
position on this topic and he endeavored
to one-up them by adopting a position
even more incoherent and morally insane
and he succeeded in his goal Against All
Odds he succeeded
it's bad enough to argue that some
little girls are actually boys inside
and need to be surgically and medically
altered to turn them into their true
selves
it's even worse to acknowledge that all
of that is nonsense
and yet defend a parent's right to
mutilate their children anyway so French
as he says knows that boys aren't girls
and yet is now willing to call it is not
is not willing to call it child abuse
when a parent has a boy physically and
permanently damaged in order to make him
into what he isn't and can never be
you know a mom who throws her son out
the window because she thinks that he's
really a bird
is dangerous and psychotic obviously
but the sane man who sits by and watches
it happen and even defends the mother's
right to do it
is something even worse I would say
so contrary to what French claims leave
loving families alone
is neither a constitutional nor moral
command it is rather the platitude of
the intellectually lazy
I would say that
a parent who permanently disfigures
their children and sets them up for a
lifetime of confusion Despair and regret
are not by any definition of the term
loving because to love is to will the
good of the other and castrating and
sterilizing your children is not willing
their good but rather willing their
misery and their eventual suicide and
it's not just my subjective opinion that
it isn't good to do this to a child it's
a moral fact
it is so fundamental so basic so
self-evident that to deny it is to
invalidate any and all moral statements
because if we cannot say that it is
plainly evil to castrate and mutilate
children then we cannot say that
anything is evil I cannot think of a
definition of evil that would not
include to start with this form of abuse
and besides even if this abuse does
align with a parent's perverted idea of
love so what
not everything done in the Name of Love
is okay or moral nor should it all be
permissible under the law just because
someone said it was loving obviously
here David I'll I will uh I'll tell you
a singular moral command here's one
protect the innocent
children are innocent
and they
cannot consent to being brutalized in
this way they cannot consent to it it is
happening to them it is happening to
their bodies their lives they cannot
consent
who gives a damn if the parent consents
to it what does that matter
the fact that their parent consents to
it is irrelevant
and will do the child no good as he
grows older
when a young girl enters adulthood
without her breasts without her voice
without her ability to have children all
of that permanently deprived of her
taken away stolen
what difference does the parents
previous consent make
who cares is she supposed to take solace
in that while she's forced to live every
day for the rest of her life with the
tattered remains of her Womanhood
is she going to live the next
six Decades of her life saying well at
least my parents consented to it when I
was 14.
if you're so focused on rights
why not focus on the right of a child to
be free from grave bodily harm
does a child have that right David does
a child not have that god-given right
what about a child's right to their own
body their own identity their own future
let me ask you this do parents have the
right to mutilate their children
or do children have the right to not be
mutilated
that is the central question that is the
question right there
and one with an obvious answer if you
ask me
it's it's the most obvious and the
easiest answer imaginable
yet it's an answer that you still fail
to get right
which is amazing
and even worse you know better
and you admit that you know better
and for that reason David French is
today canceled
and we'll leave it there for this
portion of the show as we move over into
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]